We Begin this morning with breaking news
for the first time we are seeing
dramatic video of the mid-air
confrontation between Russian fighter
jets and an American surveillance drone
that crashed near Ukraine the U.S Air
Force released this video from the Drone
a short time ago saying it shows a
Russian jet buzzing and eventually
colliding with the aircraft Ouija James
at the White House with all the latest
Ouija good morning Adriana good morning
to you and good morning to everybody
before that footage was made public
Russia denied hitting the unarmed drone
calling its very presence a provocation
and accusing the U.S of increasing its
spy operation now that defense officials
have released the video the White House
continues to call Russia's Bluff
newly released video overnight shows
recently Declassified footage of a
Russian fighter jet colliding with the
U.S drone over the Black Sea this week
the footage released Thursday by the
defense department supports the account
by U.S officials that two Russian jets
made a total of 19 passes on the unarmed
drone drenching it with their jet fuel
on the final pass the Russian pilot
appeared to miss his approach causing a
collision American controllers
deliberately crashed the damage drone
into the sea but insisted it had every
right to be in the sky make no mistake
the United States will continue to fly
and to operate wherever international
law allows this was an intentional
Russian attack on the Drone former
acting director of the CIA Michael
Morrell says Russia likely raced to
recover the debris they would like to
take a look at it to Simply see if
there's anything that they can learn
from it about U.S capabilities U.S
officials say the Russians arrived to
the scene first about 60 miles Southwest
of the Crimean Peninsula but recovering
debris won't be easy it's probably about
maybe four or five thousand feet of
water or something like that so any
recovery operation is very difficult at
that depth officials say that the
Russians will probably find some pieces
of the Drone like metal chunks but the
U.S military wiped its software to
remove sensitive intelligence we are
quite confident that whatever whatever
laws of value is no longer a value
defense secretary Lloyd Austin spoke
with his Russian counterpart for the
first time in five months Wednesday a
signal that both sides are taking this
Collision seriously it's important that
great Powers be models of transparency
and communication
much of this conflict is about control
and air space over the Black Sea now
Russia's pushed to dominate the region
creates instability for three NATO
allies that share a shoreline critical
to trade across Europe which is of
course already vulnerable as the war
rages on Vlad
all right Ouija thank you very much